what's up y'all it's your boy Marcellus
Wally dad dude yes sir y'all know where
I'm at check out my boy bootleg Kev on
this podcast why why
it's the boole camp podcast special
guests in here
NFL legend TV Legend got a great YouTube
channel right now that part Marcellus
Wiley is here yeah what it do baby
what's up buddy good to see you oh
thanks for the free drink of course all
right you pulling up man
um yeah it's crazy because I've been
watching you for so long on TV man like
oh my God hardcore Sports just maniac
and between your NFL career to your TV
career which is almost as legendary as
your NFL career not a lot of people have
double digit like real runs on TV yeah
you know what I'm saying yeah and I when
I think of like everything you did at
ESPN and then helping build FS1 into
what it is today like
um what's going on right now because
you're obviously not on TV right now no
not right now and maybe not right ever
right no because why I mean yeah I mean
the YouTube channel is going well and
you can say whatever you want yeah it's
a whole different animal now when you
talk about sports media
um but not to get that deep into it um
I guess to take you back uh I was going
to be a school teacher and I just kept
getting bigger faster stronger ended up
being a football player but my heart and
my mind has always been locked in and
helping others yeah
um forking the road kids uh because I
was that kid growing up you know and I
didn't think I was special and I don't
think in those terms that you got to be
special to have success right it's just
a science to life that you got to make
sure that you buy into and follow your
passions and properly enhance your
talents and things go well for you and
that could look a lot of different ways
for me it was going to be working at La
unified right in the ninth grade
somewhere all right man that's that's
all I needed
um but things took different turns and
detours and you know happy with my
journey
you fast forward from there so I had
this moment where I'm getting recruited
by all these schools and everybody's
like oh where you going where you going
where'd you go to high school at in
Compton uh no I didn't go to school
at because you grew up in Compton yeah
so I'm from Compton born raised there to
like age five age six then we move off
Slauson and greener pastures okay and
that turned into South Central so yeah
my family just kept going to other
places my grandmother from watts to
Compton mother Compton South Central
um I went to Westchester for two years
Saint Monica's had to get up super early
five in the morning to ride with my mom
all the way out to Santa Monica
um so I was gonna be the school teacher
man and then all of a sudden I'm getting
recruited by all these schools and it's
for football and just growing up the way
I grew up and knowing I've seen more
talented guys than me right knowing uh
kind of the hood tales that go on you
know this guy didn't make it all this
guy came back with an excuse all this
guy said coach tripping I just kept
hearing it and um I decided to go to
Columbia so I go to Ivy League school
and it was a roll of the dice people
were like oh damn you ain't gonna go to
the NFL from the Ivy League school and I
was like all right I'm not the type that
cares what people's right good or bad or
more I add up those with me and not
against me so then you you fast forward
I do get drafted I get drafted second
round I play 10 years and then I had
that moment again where I was like I'm a
broadcast now people think about it in
different terms than they did back then
right 2006 2007 if you were a
broadcaster there was like a stigma
almost like damn you just finished
playing ball and you're gonna spend all
your money you got to go work again
right right a little of that Magic
Johnson certainly helped and a couple
other people that you get Jalen Rose was
around back then you know
yeah so it was kind of like weird oh gee
John Sally on the Best Damn Sport show
remember that yes so I used to go and he
didn't help the narrative because people
were like oh John Sally he was kind of
like bouncing around right right right
he wasn't the best yeah yeah you see
what I'm saying yeah and it was a weird
place and I'm not slighting anybody I'm
just telling you how the landscape was
and I it was real resistance like I was
telling my boys in the locker room in
Jacksonville dog I'm about to go
broadcast for what you're supposed to go
somewhere and mess with girls and get
fat and golf right and I was like dog I
can't do that so I rolled the dice there
and then everything took off from there
working that NFL Network ESPN Fox and at
this I just right now I'm in my Columbia
slash broadcasting slash independent
world now where you got to roll the dice
and bet on yourself because I just see
how everything's getting fractured right
now yeah no I think that that's like uh
if anything even like me because I
traditionally worked and I'm still on
the radio every night here in LA but I
do it my own way they they contract my
show I'm syndicated so I don't record my
show from wherever I'm at but it's like
I feel like nowadays if you're gonna be
a part of media or create content like
that is if as long as you're good and
you're and people are interested yeah
like I feel like you got to kind of do
what you're doing do what I'm doing it's
like build your own platform yeah man
and I'm late to the game even though
some people are saying I'm still early
because I mean you're relatively early
you look at guys like Pat McAfee who's
like the guy you know and like the bar
stool guys but like you're pretty early
yeah I mean in terms of like platform
like you know McAfee unintended
consequences like he wanted to work at
ESPN Etc didn't get the opportunity
thank God right and so he had to you
know he was forced to do it his way yeah
um I wasn't in that position I'm not in
that position now but I just saw the
rewards not only in terms of on the
extremes the success like you know him
or Joe Rogan or Nepal Brothers like just
damn but more than that they were doing
it their way they're authentic and from
what I was doing and I see it happening
now with Stephen A Smith
when you do Network TV no matter how
real you are it's coming off fake like
people ain't feeling you like you think
they're feeling you yeah and there's and
you still can't be 100 honest right you
have to still be very aware of yeah and
it's not just corporate sponsors and
partners that's the lazy layer everyone
thinks it's better that nah it's because
of who you're working with so you got
teammates when you do it that way and
your teammates
to protect them from looking bad or
losing or them at times you
you got to play this game where we can't
go all the way I can't I can't disagree
with you to the fullest like I would in
real life right like no I don't believe
that that's some [__] yeah but then
you know in the air it's like you can't
say that you gotta be political you got
to be it's for the sake of good TV you
gotta you know yeah you gotta let them
represent the other side even though
you're like there's no other side on it
right right so I got a little fatigue to
that a little law of Association because
if you let stuff live then your brand
how people really process you becomes
this hybrid of who that is who that is
who you are and it's like it's just too
much gumbo and I was like damn I'm not
as authentic in reception as I thought I
would be at this point in my career like
48 years old been doing this 20 almost
30 years and cats is still not
understanding purely what I'm about
right they were like oh I like you from
Sportsnation you were funny but then on
FS1 y'all were too deep and I'm like dog
I'm funny and deep what the hell you're
like they try to splice you both yeah
yeah so I got a little fatigued that at
the law of Association I would say the
same thing at ESPN the same exact thing
at Fox and one of them was like whatever
and the other one's like oh you sell out
are you mean or you change are you
different so I just kind of got tired of
being washed away with all that I was
gonna say have you watched uh because I
just saw
Stephen A replied to Dan levitar I saw
that you saw that and he's he's gussing
and [__] he's going in and I was like oh
[__] I was like Stephen A Smith is uh
he's unraveled I love it like but he
wouldn't be able to do that on TV that's
to my point man it's a whole different
animal so you know you kind of get to
just be undressed you know you get to
walk around the house [__] baby boys
want some breakfast like that's a
podcast to me and I was getting jealous
when I was at Fox no lie I'm watching
Jason Whitlock who left
um regardless of the content I just like
that no no but he has his own his thing
he's got his name yeah yeah and I was
like damn and I was watching all these
other cats out here YouTubers moving in
my neighborhood and I'm like damn it
took me 10 years of football 20 years of
broadcasting these suckers and moving in
next door I was like yo the game
changing for sure when am I gonna bet on
myself at 48 or 52 when I get fat and
full again and then you know it was a
hybrid you know Fox and I discussed a
couple of hybrid situations but I'm so
focused on my family like to a point
where I don't like to travel at all and
people like damn you wanna go here go I
don't want to go on the boys trips no
dog I don't did all that plus yeah
you've already done it all yeah and then
get caught so I'm like I'm living
um I want to be with my kids I want to
help raise them I don't want to provide
for them right but I'm distant right in
that yeah because I feel like when
you're a certain level of success that
era has to kind of happen right it's
very rare that you can
be super present and still but like I
feel like once you hit that Comfort area
where you're like hey like now I can
really apply myself to being at home and
yeah because I did all the tough work 20
years ago 10 years ago yeah built it you
mentioned Jason Whitlock he obviously
another guy who has had a very long
career on TV he's also very polarizing
film oh Big Time major you guys did
speak for yourself together yep um which
I believe that was your first that you
guys started that show together nah
Colin coward and Jason Whitlock started
it it was that's right it was calling in
him yeah so you came in once Colin went
and and and just focused in on the
radios yes TV
um what was it like working with him
because he has a lot of very interesting
opinions yeah a lot of people say he's
kind of like Uncle Ruckus yeah the memes
I've seen the memes man you know like
he's seen them too
um Wheelock is Whitlock one thing about
him you could say whatever
he is about what he believes and what he
says and that's what I like now that
doesn't mean he lives out all of that
I'm saying his opinion is going to be
unwavering unless challenged by
something greater right and I love that
I don't care sure how you get up to the
top of your mountain man there's so many
different paths I'm not here to judge in
that respect but be you that's what I
love the most about them now what's
tough for being with Whitlock is he's
always going to throw some extra hot
sauce on no matter what he says it could
be the most simple of takes
he's gonna put some spice on it right
and at times I feel that's unnecessary
but that's how he serves it so you got
to either eat it or you're gonna be mad
at it you know and um
I remember when he first I worked with
him at ESPN at a time at times right and
then we've he started coming over to
crib he was like yo your contract up you
need to come over here got this family
style show we're going to do kind of
like The Cosby Show for sports and you
know you're such a great father and what
you represent you're such a good dude
and um he was like I could let you have
the platform to do that right now I'm
coming off Sports Nation which was which
was great shout out Michelle Beadle
shout out Michelle Beadle Max Kellerman
Thompson here's a great show oh man
Carrie Champion LZ Granderson and that
was part of the point I could name too
many damn co-hosts right so here I go
again I'm going this way I'm going this
way I got so many teammates couldn't
build up like brand chemistry
um but I loved it all I love the
experience and you know our show was
light-hearted personally it was great it
was a great show oh yeah yeah so we had
a ball but then he started talking to me
about this I was like it'd be probably
good right now to change it up so I'll
go over there and love my experience
over there to the fullest only two
things that really changed what maybe
three things that changed my whole
complexion of how that experience was
going was one the pandemic when the
pandemic hit you know everybody got any
feelings everybody started separate
separating getting polarized and even
more than before more than before right
so I'm like damn yep I'm just trying to
take care of the kids make sure they
ain't on the iPod and iPads right 25
hours a day you know way too much and um
that was part one part two was Whitlock
left you know kind of in the middle of
the night even though I had heads up I
knew people that knew his situation a
little Disturbed he didn't tell me
straight up because then you if he
convinced you to come over right right
so if if anything is percolating right
you're supposed to let give me the heads
up I agree Max Kellerman did that with
First Take day one he was like hey dog
what you think I'm thinking this let's
talk through it not like I got the
overall decision making no but it's it's
a courtesy right yeah and I didn't get
that with like I had to know it and then
just had to see him every day then
finally he dipped and I was like oh
that's that was real dude all good but
he left and that kind of left the
imprint on me like all right this thing
ain't like the team you think this is
which I kind of knew already but it got
hit in the face again and the last thing
was my agent left
um my agent was a super agent too still
my homie
um still the man Nick Khan who went to
WWE now he runs WWE and he basically
told me on the way out he was like look
he had a ton of clients he's like look
man every now I know you gotta swing for
the fences and he's like I've been
hitting a lot of base hits Doubles
Doubles inside the park home runs right
right right right like like he was
killing it no one thought he probably
from the outside should left but now
he's running WWE a billion dollar
company thank you that part so you know
he was just like you gotta swing for the
fences and that was a seed that was
planted that didn't Blossom until my
contract was up and I was like damn I'm
just feeling all that so long story
short working with Whitlock
it was great it was the challenge was
not us doing the show it was people here
him and didn't hear me so you know we do
a segment even though I'm challenging
them or supporting them they didn't hear
me they heard Whitlock because he got
the spicier of the takes yeah I'm I'm
not a debater I'm a discussor I'll talk
long I'll talk strong yeah he's gonna
say the crazy highlight the stuff that
gets clipped and puts on Twitter and
right and that was challenging because
that's not who I am I'm a base like that
I'm listening to all perspectives to
grow A New Perspective and I just got a
little fatigued to that but I still was
going to roll with it because I really
cared about the show and I really like
what we were doing do you feel like at
times like would you ever run into any
uh
issues when he would take a position on
something oh yeah a ton and you're on
the show with them so do you get
associated with that or are they like yo
fam like what are you doing like yeah
because he was saying some of the
Kaepernick [__] I don't I don't know if
that timeline lines up with speak for
yourself but just some of the things he
was saying about cap and [__] where I
was just like yeah yeah you know it was
just like a little like off-putting I
guess to hear that on like you know I I
I again even like you know
we talk about him leaving and doing his
own thing but hearing that on like ESPN
or Fox at the time it's kind of crazy
some of the things he was saying yeah
and you know without particulars like
um Kaepernick was a hot button issue I
didn't mind that because you know I I
don't even know how you say this
properly but uh I had my issues with
Kaepernick as well but no I think I
think I think as the way you say it well
I think as it kind of the cap thing I
think as it wavered and I it felt like
he really had real opportunities I think
that that Atlanta thing that happened
where he had the workouts yeah and he
wanted to do the workout his way yeah I
was like bro they're giving you the yo I
mean I I I people have come up to me and
literally said can I talk to you for a
sec I I'm sorry I apologize I don't even
know these cats yeah I thought you were
sellout I thought you were against us
and all that and I was like dog I don't
even believe in all that stuff you're
talking about I just tell you what I see
from my perspective and my experiences
or any situation I knew Kaepernick
before all that uh I haven't talked to
him since but I saw the 180 fine you
know I see that ain't the first I guess
for me it was just like the demonization
of someone just kneeling to bring
attention to something obviously you get
into
three or four years later down the road
the lawsuit like he cashed out you know
what I'm saying and then he still had an
opportunity so that's that's the point
though this is the funny I I always tell
people I am not a hater right I just
tell the truth too early and I've said
it wait like day one I'm like I could
read this like it's like if you take me
to a workout and show me some defensive
ends right I need three reps I could
tell you who this and who down here that
fast so I read the situation accurately
um from that moment doesn't mean he's
not doing work but you said it best he
he brought attention but I don't think
the attention was going where everyone
thought it was going a lot of it was
coming back to be self-serving but he's
still doing the work I ain't even mad at
him but I was just like yo this ain't
gonna go like y'all think it's going the
way in the first play he could have had
was challenged the NFL not be
adversarial but challenge the NFL to do
exactly what he wanted but what did he
want he didn't know that's why he didn't
do any q and A's he didn't go out there
didn't do a lot of energy views into any
podcasts you mean a lot you mean none
none then also took that money and
didn't say any I mean he I mean we don't
know how much it was right no but I'm
sure the condition of him getting that
money was everything is
yeah if you're the NFL of course you're
going to make them sign the NDA of
course you're going to say you can't go
out there and damage our brand but hey
act like you want to play every single
year yeah that's what you said it's like
if you really really really wanted to
still play I feel like that that Atlanta
thing the way he moved the workout last
minute I was just like people act like
this this at that point I was like guys
okay we got like you a couple years
after me when I was like guys yeah I
know I was I was for sure because it
took me a while but when that happened I
was like ah this is this ain't it what's
going on oh you know what's going on and
it's just funny because I know too many
guys that would die for a workout like I
know dudes that are beasts Ballers right
give me a workout dog that's rap it's on
and this guy had multiple chances and
opportunities and a workout and a
settlement and y'all trying to act like
they trying to keep him down maybe you
don't want to get up that's all I looked
at it and it wasn't that deep for me
right people act like he was the Lord
and Savior I'm like no government nobody
out here is saving you from your world
because if it works or it doesn't work
you still got to do the work so I'm like
why did everyone get so wrapped up in
that it was kind of crazy but to your
point Whitlock and I agree like this
ain't it right but he agreed in a way
where people like damn dogs yeah kind of
caught up in a little right right right
right right but I did my part too
um yo it's crazy so obviously we just
saw everybody get let go at ESPN it was
I mean and they've had a lot of cuts
before yeah Stephen A did a good job of
putting that out on his show like where
were you in this year and all these
people got fired and then this year all
these people got fired yeah but again
your boy Max got let go yeah who is one
of my favorites especially when it comes
to boxing I love when he is is working
the fights
um you know for people who don't know
Max Kellerman used to be a rapper
seriously I don't even get him started
uh clip out there yeah
um but have you spoken with Max oh yeah
how's he doing and like for you to you
know I mean obviously as somebody who's
kind of doing your own thing now to
witness a line of cuts like that
happening I mean we're talking about
Jeff Van Gundy I know Jalen yeah those
two those are the first two that caught
me off guard
no no I think the max thing we kind of
saw coming yeah exactly Jeff Van Gundy I
was like damn but damn one all right so
Jeff Van Gundy that one caught me the
most off guard but then my second mind
kicked in is like hey bro he'd be going
in on on the NBA for sure partner of
Israel I can understand that do you dive
a little deeper you realize maybe there
was a little uh maybe yeah coffee and
tea and yeah can you let him go or else
it's gonna be tougher in our next
negotiation maybe that
um Jalen Rose caught me off guard but
then I was like yeah him and Max kind of
in the same boat they start chipping
away at what your what your products are
your entities so no more him Jalen and
Jacoby then this happens right because
the Jacoby Jalen show got cut first he
got cut first max no first take for a
while this just in which felt like a
filler show like all right you're not
here here you go yeah but how I don't
think Max leaves our show leaves LA to
do this just in and people don't think
like this but you get that in
consolation but this is why I left ESPN
in a less forced Nation it's one thing
to be getting paid and Max was getting
paid but he got paid to do first take
and now here they go with their plan B
like okay you don't Steve Steven they
don't want you on first take anymore we
got this for you right yeah but that
ain't for you that's just something to
kind of fill the time it's something for
us to to justify us paying you still
exactly yeah and so there's a huge
difference between them paying you and
them supporting you right now I feel
that Sports Nation with all the rotating
hosts and co-hosts and I was like they
paying me but they don't I don't see
foresight I don't see Runway I don't see
where they're all invested in the next
five years of the show and it was tough
to call their Bluff because every time
you say that they're like oh of course
we are of course we are right and then I
said all right I'ma leave and as soon as
I left they canceled that show proving
my point I was on thin ice the show was
on thin ice one day they'll just wake up
and be like ah Sports Nation it was
novel back then 10 years ago now
everyone has a touch screen yeah
everyone interacts with the fans and
social media so I I was like uh I got
ahead of that one I felt the same for
Max I was thinking like damn this ain't
gonna last this just in even though it
wasn't a bad show it just wasn't the
show he would have left L.A to go and do
that right so so that coming man and you
know he has a little time on he has time
to work with in terms of still getting
paid by ESPN develop what's next he's
certainly in the running for Undisputed
depending on how they really do that but
they're talking about their rotating
partnership what they're doing at ESPN
they might do it FS1 yeah which makes
sense which they actually got from skip
so I want to clarify everybody thinks
Stephen A started this back in the day
that's what skip used to do that's what
skip used to do people don't remember
that cold pizza was always like Woody
page or Stephen A or the twin the Stu
Stu twins I remember them I I know
you're talking about uh God I forget
Monty Jones was on a lot of people
come on there yeah so it was a thing
before Steven A revamped it and now skip
may go back to it
um let me ask you this do you feel like
the way because I I feel like the Pat
McAfee thing happening and then all of
this these Cuts happening and Stephen A
starting his own show I've like none of
these are coincidental oh no it's not
right I'm like okay well they had to pay
this guy however much they had to pay
him for him to walk away from that
FanDuel deal which shout out to him for
yeah being comfortable enough to do that
but at the same time you got oh look
Stephen A launches his own thing on
YouTube like do you feel like Pat McAfee
in the same way that Skip and Stephen a
kind of changed what moves the needle in
traditional TV ratings on Sports
networks with debate by the way PTI was
the first to kind of do that but
um Do You Feel Like Pat McAfee's
changing the sports broadcasting
industry yeah he's he's the one that
shows the proof of concept the best in
sports
um you know you combine that with the
Paul Brothers you combine that with Joe
Rogan yeah yeah everything starts
getting crazy right but in sports it's
McAfee
um and the beautiful thing is I I keep
going back to it he ain't even raised
his hand to do it but you know what he
was doing he didn't know it
um he was falling in an alignment where
the industry had to go so let's go way
back to like 98.99 when Bill Gates first
said content is King and everyone's
heard that right but we didn't really
understand it because we didn't have the
proper mediums and the proper conduits
to do that so content is King before
social media is really big meant what I
stay in the studio longer my show is
longer what's content is Keen but what
he really meant then and I was just at a
summit speaking in Silicon Valley about
this where all the tech Guru CEOs are
talking VCS now that this world
especially Sports media is going to
change and morph into everyone is a
Creator and everyone is a channel now
some people are already pushing back
probably thinking I ain't a channel I'm
not a Creator everybody is if you got an
Instagram well no let's go old school
Facebook you like oh yeah you're a
content creator technically yes if
someone is following you that's giving
you attention if you post something
someone's given that some sort of
attention you might get two likes there
you go that is content you may get two
likes but if you talk about interaction
engagement did someone slow down on it
right there yeah because that's what
they look on the back here they're
trying to measure those metrics and
they're like oh that was interesting
okay now we're going to change your feed
algorithm for that point being you are a
creator
on a grander scale that is Pat McAfee he
just started to plug away during a
three-hour show every single day and
falling into alignment where everything
had to go so now everything is going out
and very unedited very unhinged when it
came to the language he's using it it
was like oh this guy doesn't work for
nobody so he could say whatever the [__]
he was he wants and it was sick and I I
mean and he played you know I'm watching
one of my contemporaries doing the same
thing broadcasting right play ball like
I did and then I'm watching him in a
tank top curse about the same topic that
I'm over here hello in a suit you look
at all Prima price it's like who who's
the fans going to want to see they want
to see the uncut version of that or
right I wanted to see yeah so I'm like
you know getting off the studio desk
everyone is bowing down to me oh look
marcelon TV linear cable respect which
it is of course of course it's a
different animal if it wasn't Pat McAfee
wouldn't be on ESPN if it didn't matter
because it does still matter because he
he took he's
he a lot of people think he walked away
from you know maybe a little bit more
money no they got that wrong too oh did
they let me tell you all right so let's
just say the FanDuel deal is 120.
if it's 120 that's what they reported
and then it gets 85 from ESPN everybody
already initially kind of ran with it
the wrong way
120 from FanDuel is here Pat do
everything else with it pay every pay
yourself
yeah pay the whole crew whoever Rox man
Jones everybody all of them yeah and run
that operation and you deal with all
that tax attorneys yeah or I give you 85
and then we pay your crew and then I go
AJ come here you come in here next
nobody talking about his deal Asia
here's your five year 25 whatever it may
be so everybody starts getting that it
grows greater than the 120 he got from
FanDuel and everybody's secure everyone
gets their health insurance through
somebody it ain't on Pat McAfee's
diamonds Etc all these truths the
benefits like it's insane so he took a
better deal on top of a grander platform
and he's gonna be able to do so much if
he just hosted the ass piece you know
like they threw him in last minute last
minute and he killed it he killed it
that's that's the thing like he still
gets to do what he's doing but he also
gets that turbo boost that nitrous from
ESP by the way shout out to AJ Hawk for
never having to leave his house and and
and just they somehow did such a good
job because you know I'm so against Zoom
content like when we do interviews and
stuff for the most part if something
yeah I noticed that when we were setting
it up you're like bruh
look like if if Drake was like we have
to do it all right Drake's that's what
you're saying I'm just I mean like
you're what you're but you're in town
you know like I think we've maybe done
two or three Zoom interviews in the last
three years I think one of them was uh
Tyrese you let Tyrese off the hook he
from L.A no man we did after that we did
that more for the radio Drake got a spot
in in L.A too so who you letting off the
hook these people these cats live in L.A
dog TLC
all right
uh but yeah it wasn't what was the other
one oh yeah and then like uh but for my
[__] I think that's the only two like oh
and then goodie mop they were in Atlanta
and it was middle of the panda oh okay
so this was like early pandemic they
don't dance no more okay I'll give you
some of that but but but they've done a
good job of figuring out a way to make
the remote thing work oh yeah ESPN does
that everybody dude nobody even notices
anymore yes because I think in the
hip-hop space people notice really yeah
like when you're not doing like an
in-person interview in the music space
people notice that's a great Point
Sports we're so used to seeing everybody
Mike wilbon's in Arizona or yes
cornhusers in DC yeah and so like you
know just kind of finish your point and
finish what we were talking about
everyone's gonna become a Creator you
already are but you're gonna become like
you're gonna lean into it and really
realize that's who you are even if
you're an old lady just sitting there
showing pictures of your grandkids
you're a Creator what comes from that
is now you're going to all understand
you have to license that out
um and what ESPN just bought into was
the first licensing of a Creator yeah so
they now it's a proof of concept on
YouTube second most Googled which Google
owns YouTube but second most used search
engine is YouTube right behind Google
which owns YouTube yeah so what they are
doing is they're like ah we're creating
what has to be created with your
creators right now traditional media
whether that's linear cable or
traditional media has to now buy into
all of us because we are where the
people are so reason I took off my suit
ultimately is I was making 1.9 million
dollars I hate this world we can't tell
kids and people how much you're making
like in football everybody know how much
you make right everybody everybody they
know every little detail every little
Clause yeah point zero well you know if
it makes it Pro Bowl this year that's an
extra 500k or Kyler Murray has to study
right and then I get it that was funny
um these thin like these these like
fragile egos or fragile industry well
and we saw a lot of these salaries the
guys who just got fired and you're like
God yeah I'm like why are we High guys
like Keyshawn Johnson was eating not not
was he signed a five-year deal and only
did one year of it he's getting paid for
the next four years when I saw the
Keyshawn Johnson number and listen the
morning show was decent it wasn't great
Keyshawn is a decent all like like
obviously a legendary player he's done a
great job dog that's not a dog yeah
listen L.A Legend SC Legend oh here come
my butt
when I saw that number
I was like oh you forgot Keyshawn always
hit him over the head
contract his agent
I think he's his own agent whoever
agency is negotiating his check I said
oh man good for him but you know the
real of that is he got that deal
God let me let me untangle this for
y'all so max is making that big first
take money right then they're like all
right Stephen A and him ain't going
right mix water and oil they ended up
putting Max on with Keyshawn right yeah
yeah that morning show yeah so this is
how it is Keyshawn was already there
they got rid of the Zubin guy right he
got sick and then it just left something
like that so then Max comes in but Max
making first take money that's the most
expensive morning show ever right for a
radio show right at all time so did
Keyshawn sitting there like um he came
to my hood this my show whose name is
first Keyshawn yeah so he used that as
leverage that's how he got that though
oh hey let's stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our good Folks
at King Palm that's right man shout out
to King Palm uh we're talking about
nothing but that organic all right that
natural
Them Leafs all right there's no tobacco
involved and they're so smooth when you
smoke in them I love King Palms the only
thing I'm smoking out of now if you go
to your local uh liquor store you go to
your local smoke shop you can get King
Palms of course 7-Eleven's got the king
pongs and they have so many crazy
flavors like shout out to Sugar Shawn
who's from um
Phoenix Arizona my hometown he's got his
own flavor they just sent us these now
what's dope about King Palm is that they
have the the terpene infused flavors so
at the end of the tip of these pre-rolls
right you get the Leaf
you squeeze the tip that's what she said
and then you just get a burst of flavor
this is that honey mango all right now
this is the most important part this is
absolutely natural
tobacco-free leaves the cleanest way to
smoke all right trust me when I say it
man we love King Palm over here so many
flavors I mean shout out to the grape
shots of the honey mango shout out to
the sugar punch right here you know what
I'm saying look if you go to kingpom.com
right now you can get hooked up with
everything you need at 50 off if you use
the promo code bootleg
or bootleg Kev try either one of those I
forget which one it is it's bootleg or
it's bootleg Kev you know what the
correct promo code will be down below
use the one that's down here kingpom.com
get 50 off right now shout out to King
pong
also want to shout out to our good Folks
at Blue chew baby shout out to Bluetooth
now this was going on with Bluetooth man
everybody keeps asking me this Bluetooth
work yes it works but don't take my word
for it you're gonna get a month for free
when you go to bluetooth.com and you use
the promo code bootleg a month for free
now what is Bluetooth fellas if you're
dealing with erectile dysfunction fellas
if your dick is not getting as hard as
you'd like it to maybe for your wife oh
I don't know listen all you got to do is
go to bluetooth.com it has the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
but it's getting delivered to you in a
chewable form right to your door in
discreet packaging and you do not have
to go into a doctor's office to get
Bluetooth you go to bluetooth.com you
use the promo code bootleg you get a
month supply delivered to your door
discretely of course
discreetly
no doctor's appointments no going and
leaving your house and sitting in a
Lobby and waiting for some you know lady
to call you in so you could tell her how
your cock's not working properly it
happens fellas all right bluetooth.com
take my word for it also take their word
for it because they're going to give you
a month's supply for free just five
dollar shipping bootry.com promo code
bootleg uh let's get back to the
interview this is games so if you were
making you were making 1.9 I was making
1.9 which is you know I mean like I'm an
A minus territory mostly that's great
though most people you see don't make
that and you were you being were you in
LA or you were going to uh Connecticut
L.A okay all L.A which was great it was
a great fit for my life it's just it I
plateaued first of all I'm the realest
it's just like being an athlete I knew
when I was sorry right now everyone else
will say it before me but I acknowledge
it when y'all saying it too when an
athlete's coming down the hill he knows
it he just ain't gonna admit it he won't
admit it everyone else is gonna say it
so I knew I would Plateau because the
three big dogs in my industry I never
could be like them and that's a positive
for them and just a difference for me
Stephen A Skip and Colin so this is how
I look at life man it's the science of
life I'm like all right all three of
them didn't play at the highest level
so there's a different level of
communication and investment right then
I'm like all right they all go places I
wouldn't go because I'm not trying to be
condensed into that great headline
that's spicy I don't go in on the camera
you'll notice a lot less of the crueler
takes coming from actual people who
played right exactly so I was like damn
I'm not a hot take artist
um and people think that's with a
negative connotation I'm like no that's
just a brand we're all in the circus
just different tents my tent is not that
so I was like so how much can I make in
my tent now start looking around like
think you making the most in this tent
bro so I was like do you bet again my
next negotiation was going to be a
haircut using the pandemic and of course
all this stuff so I was like then I'm
looking at my neighbors I'm like these
suckers are going downstairs in these
content houses destroying life and
moving in next to me so I was like all
right we talked through the negotiation
basically
I started my own show downstairs in my
house I'm just going downstairs so it
was your decision to leave FS1 so yeah
so that's on your own terms both times
Well if they would pay me 10 million but
both times leaving ESPN and FS1 you left
on your own oh yeah like there well
there are other opportunities and shows
for me to go there yeah no but you you
were like hey I'm gonna move on to FS1
because I have a a place where maybe I
can showcase who I am more yeah and then
once the FS1 thing ran its course yeah
free agency like you got other offers
are they better offers my mind at
leaving FS1 was this
there was three levels of me Landing the
plane the first one was we're not doing
speak for yourself anymore because
whitlock's not here who designed that
whole show he was there from the
beginning well you're there when it
became you weren't there when it became
speak no no that's when I was out
because they were telling me about that
right and I was like damn I'm going
backwards in life no slight to them
because I already did Sports Nation and
I was like I've already done the the
four person panel all that you've been
there done and they're done that the top
layer we're going to talk about Cowboys
we're going to talk the Lakers I've done
that and I was like damn I got so many
more muscles to flex that I won't get
the flex in that format on this show but
they paying you so much they're paying
you to be in that velvet coffee right
right like just just die slowly with us
shut up you know what I mean and so I
was like damn
level two was the fact that the offer
wasn't going to be as Grand as my
imagination of being out here being on
YouTube letting Brands plug into me
sponsors plug into me going direct to
Consumer and number three was frankly we
start talking about other shows building
the show out in my home which we started
um first things first which I love but
it's in New York it was conversations of
it coming to La it didn't happen then I
was like now I'm going I'm chasing money
because the only reason I'm gonna do
this is because they're paying me I
would never want to be in New York away
from my kids I would never want to go
over here and be away from my kids and
just travel and do the circuit I
right but I don't want to do do that and
then you know using my network and
knowing what I know and wanted to lean
into my Foundation I said you know what
Just Do Your Own Thing regain do the
work man yeah it won't come and then
let's roll and then YouTube's doing well
it is man and you you guys I mean almost
six months do you have
um somebody handling your brand
Partnerships and your sponsorships or do
you do a lot of that yourself or do you
yeah someone's handling it but I I mean
I'm always cc'd I'm always chiming in uh
you know only I know my own secret sauce
did they get your Bluetooth yet the
Bluetooth are you Bluetooth up yet what
is that you got to get that Bluetooth
man what is that they sponsor our show
oh is that some food or something dipped
uh it's like a dick pill
my wife said get it
everywhere
in Cialis use the promo code bootleg oh
and you'll get a month for free boys
smooth with that okay uh you mentioned
talking about the Cowboys and Lakers
yeah yeah is it ever I mean listen you
are a uh a unicorn in the sense that you
are one of the very few people who I
know from Los Angeles who chose the
Clippers
and kudos to you for that because it's
an original thought I appreciate that
um
but original team two we ain't from
Minnesota when you guys are getting fed
every you know like like you said
there's the Lakers there's the Cowboys
no matter how irrelevant or relevant
they may or may not be it seems like
they're always top of the news cycle
right yeah for you being like somebody
who's like guys like is it ever like
did it fatiguing where you're like how
many different ways can we talk about
Dak Prescott being mediocre I think you
need to ask it the other way were there
ever times I was excited I was always
fatigued to that because what we were
doing was chasing where we thought the
audience was and look let's be real if
you talk about the Cowboys and Yankees
Lakers you can say what you want people
do respond to that but you got to
remember like TV ratings are archaic
compared very archaic the way they work
yeah it's the same way radio is very
archaic so you get it so the whole point
is it's like
man all right we're using this to guide
us but it's an old ass Compass but it's
flawed it's flawed yeah so we literally
are comparing ourselves to those who are
independent creators who have comments
who actually oh you can actually see the
views you can see the view this it's a
hunch because you got this system that
yeah it's crazy right right bar is yeah
that's a backdrop at the bar yeah oh
that's a rating yeah but they ain't
watching you that's like when people say
radio ratings count when someone gets in
an Uber and someone's playing something
all whether you're listening to the
station technically it's like oh am I
like yeah just because it's on like the
engagement brand so I mean it's
fatiguing beyond especially because I'm
wired differently than most people in
this business
um
because I I've always just been a guy
who's intellectually curious and I mean
I put the actions behind that I went to
Columbia I damn near in people's eyes
and perception threw away my football
career to go to uh yeah yeah so I'm a
whole different animal that doesn't mean
I'm smarter it just means I'm a bet a
little different than you and so when we
keep going over this same topic I'm
bored as hell because I'm like bruh how
many times have we talked about this
this month and I would say that on there
which gave me a lame but also like dog
you're not this is our business model
bro like which you're over here fighting
what we do what was the if like what's
something that comes to mind the one
storyline or story or topic that maybe
over A month's time or three months time
or you were just like
enough this is crazy yeah um it's always
talking about Dak Dak top five nouns is
that top ten is that good enough to win
the Super Bowl is that good enough to
make an NFC Championship game that's
contract justify like I'm like God don't
how many different times we talk about
this one guy who's never won a Super
Bowl or an MVP
meanwhile everybody else passing them up
if you want to say it in terms of their
team is doing better right they're
winning chips we put them at the bottom
of the show it's almost like endless
Tony Romo to me was much better than Dak
Prescott but it's kind of what Tony Romo
back in the day it's like they wouldn't
stop talking about Tony Romo and it's
like yeah the number one of all though
was that Tebow fatigue oh my God yeah
people don't remember that that was
insane I remember oh I remember it
vividly and I had to work through a lot
of that all day every day every day Tim
Tebow talk yeah and Tebow won one
playoff game uh it was against the
Steelers right yeah yeah yeah True
Underdog and I love him as a human but
God if you talk about sports was that
the guy to put that much on and I
thought it came back a little bit
remember when he was on the Jaguars for
the practice squad I was like oh no he's
back I thought we got rid of him then he
wanted to play baseball yeah now I love
chasing Tim Tebow the human but the
great guy player great guy they were
doing way too much so that one all of
that Dak talks just to me as soon as I
see it I like throw up in my mouth a
little bit like come on bro how much of
um Sports media is like because because
you will always see like uh unspoken
beefs with people like I've seen I've
seen Michelle Beadle say stuff about
Rachel Nichols and obviously there's
like yeah I think it was on a podcast or
something okay
um Mama as I call her mama mama bees
don't play she don't give a damn goddamn
Spurs fan too God bless her
um but how much of it is like is there
like a lot of stuff that we don't get to
see where people really just don't [__]
with each other but they have to be on
TV with each other oh absolutely because
we've seen so much of that recently
where like
Skip and Shannon had big big blowouts or
or uh perk and uh JJ Redick or you know
there's been all these things where
you're like oh
it gets a lot of eyes and it feels a lot
more authentic than a lot of stuff we've
seen but it does seem like there's a lot
of unspoken
tension yeah in the industry that's part
of the disruption that's part of what's
leading Us in the Groundswell to go to
more Independence because both of those
scenarios has an independent Creator
content creator kind of mixed up in
there so you got Skip and Shannon all
right they've been doing this show for
seven years why y'all beefing now
independent creation which gave him the
different Lane of popularity whether you
say it's to the same level or surpass
and Skip that's something skip can't
compete with right skip has his own
podcast no one watches I can't say no
one could you got more subscribers than
me but he been around way longer than me
I'm gonna catch him real quick real
quick yeah you have great numbers for
six months dude sure it's it's going and
I'm loving it so there's a there's a
club Shay there's also a Kwame Brown
element of like stirring it up he's a
wild boy that Kwame Brown man oh funny
hilarious well stare look at you and
stir it up and then say now what you
gonna do I'm on my tractor yeah good
luck so anyway I'm just trying to get
people the Dynamics of why these things
are shifting same thing when you talk
about a situation where there's a
Stephen A and then there's a Max
Kellerman and you see that situation
you're like what's going on well because
the internet has such a loud voice so
when you're trying to protect your brand
you're almost in a reality show now
people got it twisted during the reality
show ain't hard it's when it's edited
and it's when the world gets to see it
and respond and talk about you that's
when it gets hard so skip Shannon
Stephen A Max oh we fine doing this it's
just when we go home and check oh this
is subconsciously [__] gets to you
sometimes I'm sure yeah I'm gonna sell
out oh I'm dumb oh he Cooler Than Me
Like You know I mean and then all of a
sudden you start to weave and and do
things a little differently what's your
prediction for Shannon Sharp
be wrong let me say that uh
uh before you answer yeah I think if I'm
him what I hope let me tell you what I
hope I hope he just goes all in on
himself okay what does that mean though
I think he takes Club Shay Shay to a
daily he obviously he does the inter but
I think if he did okay if he did a Daily
Show on his own channel
and he did that for a year two years and
built up leverage whatever bag he's
about to get would be way bigger because
he's got all the attention and all the
eyes on him right now that's what I
would do what do you think is going to
happen yeah like if I could and I think
the magic wand would be exactly what
McAfee did like he literally would turn
shayshay into it daily and he could let
it be on ESPN
um because there were talks of Shay
Shake being on Fox in the summer during
the the door right right now yeah
um you would let it live every single
day pour all the resources into it then
you would have like also the commercial
being on first take or something your
ESPN Club Shay Shays every day then I
chime in here and there once a week with
Stephen A because that's the biggest
Daily Show they had all right well
you're gonna have number one Daily Show
and maybe number two with Club Shay Shay
or flip that order maybe yeah you never
know while still keeping your
Independence because your licensing it
right so it's basically what the McAfee
model is how do you think he's gonna do
though
ah snap you just don't see him going
back to Fox I see him doing the once a
day once a week with with First Take
Stephen A maybe Mondays during the
football season yep I see him ramping up
Club Shay but not daily on YouTube and
continuing to leverage that I see him
leaning into his cognac
um and slanging that and I also see
him trying to build it up to a point
where
he's not
in the space he is right now which is
once a week he lateral move or promotion
would be another because you would think
like if you see the amount of money that
DraftKings gave Pat if you're saying
your FanDuel Raptor sorry no if you uh
if you're Shannon sharp you got to be
like
I'm more popular maybe maybe it's close
well not close in subscribers not in
subscriber I just mean in terms of like
star power right now Shannon sharp and
everybody's talking about Shannon sharp
as they should he's popping right now
okay my agent my uh broadcasting podcast
agent I have two but one of them
was just working on a nine-figure deal
now I can't say who because he didn't
tell me who but I kind of narrowed the
borders I was like yeah and I know I
think one of them could be Shannon the
other I'm not gonna say it I got to
protect the guilty because the guy
doesn't want it out it could be still
Shannon or somebody else but long story
short the money's out there dog nine
figures nine figures so you know that's
the old McAfee FanDuel kind of deal so
it could be Shannon but the point is I
don't see him having a Daily Show on
ESPN unless this club shayshay I would
love to see that and then let them do
first take once a week
call that a rap leverage it for a couple
years and then see what's next what's
the next Frontier who is somebody who
helped you the most in growing as a
broadcaster over the years obviously
transitioning from playing in the NFL
for 10 years coming to TV was there like
a big homie of yours that like really
kind of helped show you the ropes yeah
day one no lie I left the football field
and I didn't know how big Mike and Mike
was I knew how big ESPN was but when
you're playing I swear people think
you're lying
I didn't watch any of them shows I
didn't know they even had daily shows I
didn't know they had NFL live I think I
believe you back then I feel like
nowadays this whole heart it's very hard
to avoid it okay but yeah but back then
I get it yeah no I never heard of Mikey
Mike right I never heard of NFL live
um it was just so Random right I knew
about NFL prime time and I knew like why
Sports Center and Birmingham right Chris
Berman and yeah Jackson right right I
mean um uh what's my man I can't think
God Lee I'm bad I can't think of this
guy he played for the Broncos yes [__]
what's that God Lee y'all gonna kill me
in the comments Do It um but yeah those
guys and I was like that was a I have
made it if I made a highlight on there
right right so I'm looking around I'm
like all right I'm at ESPN day one and
they're like all right can you get up at
like five in the morning be in the
studio 5 15 and once you're on Mike and
Mike I was like all right radio show and
I was like damn
got a radio like I can't take this later
I'm like not even slighting them in my
head I'm like right I gotta do a fight
but this is my opportunity so I'm gonna
do this show called Mike and Mike and I
get there and it's Mike Greenberg Mike
Golic I just fill in for a segment you
know do a little guess appearance I'm
out and I was like I got up at five
o'clock just for one segment and then
when I was done I was like I could see
this is bigger than I thought but how
big right
got off air check my phone and it was
lit up like I signed a new deal wow I
got dang I was like Mike and Mike that
they're in every city everywhere for
however many years it was like the
longest Morning Show I mean I just
remember my whole life Mike and Mike was
on it feels like
um so which so which mic helped you out
the most Golick Golic now after that
first segment yeah
he literally comes to me and he's like
dude you're a Storyteller he's like
don't ever let somebody tell you any
different he's like everyone can do this
x's and no stuff there's computers for
that Etc he's like your stories please
just stick to your stories don't script
out your takes don't be rigid don't get
on that railroad track just tell stories
your experiences are insane to the point
where the next week they called me to
come in it was to fill in for Mike
Greenberg who was going and I literally
did a four hour show on Mike and Mike
like my second week from being just from
being like one segment early in the
morning crazy and I just ran with it I
never got boxed in to the purest version
of broadcasting which is X's and O's
third and goal what should they do or
they should play action I was like dog
I'm talking about the girls talking
about the club I'm talking about the
player talking about his life talking
about his emotions I'm I'm doing the
eyes and U's not the X's and O's and I
just kept going with that because I got
that kind Confidence from Golic when I
first got there gotta stop the interview
to tell about our good Folks at Odd
Socks baby yeah shout out to odd talks
now this is what I love about Odd Socks
one their family we love them but also
they have the most comfortable socks in
the [__] world all right now look
they got the craziest licenses you see
the Jolly Rancher these are actually
flies [__]
some Dorito socks uh they got the WWE
license which is just my absolute
favorite and then um personally my
favorite is the odd Sox Basics now these
are just the basic socks so these are in
my bag because I'm taking these
I love these Odd Socks basics
these are literally the most comfortable
socks in the world
all right these are just the plain guys
all right also they got the Scarface
they got the Godfather and they have
underwear
what are we talking about what are these
2XL Reese's Pieces you know if uh
somebody was gonna wear some Reese's
underwear I'd assume they'd be a 2x on
the size you know shots of the
Ghostbusters
um look so much going on at Odd Socks uh
what you got to do is go to
oddsoxofficial.com use that promo code
bootleg and you will save 20 off at
checkout all right it don't matter what
you're into they got all the licenses
Coca-Cola you could be a Pepsi guy
instead they got both you know what I'm
saying uh you're into maybe some anime
they got all the anime licenses they got
Naruto they also got um they just uh uh
rolled out the new uh Power Rangers
Transformers all that oddsoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg save 20 off
right now oh my goodness let me tell you
something the best part about my bookie
is not only is it the best sports book
period I mean look we're in the middle
of baseball season and baseball season
is Big Money season if you are a gambler
you know baseball is where you get this
money all right not only that but they
got the full-fledged casino going on all
right I'm telling you last night I'm on
my bookie I'm playing roulette with a
lady I'm looking at the lady she's on
video she's rolling the wheel it's a
movie all right they got Blackjack they
got uh whatever you're into Blackjack
craps uh man all kinds of slots some of
these slot games are so fun all right
listen everything you want all on one
site mybookie.ag this is the best part
when you sign up with our promo code
bootleg not only do you help us out but
you help yourself out because you're
gonna get that first deposit bonus money
to gamble with immediately free once you
sign up
mybookie.ag use the promo code bootleg
get the first deposit bonus right now
let's get back into the interview
um talk to me about your playing career
because you've obviously played it a
bunch of different places obviously uh
most notably uh but you got drafted by
Buffalo you got a great room with the
Chargers
um what was your favorite City to play
football in and what do you think was
the best team you were ever on
um by record it had to be Buffalo those
four years even though we weren't making
the Super Bowls like they were years
before was this like Rob Johnson Buffalo
yeah Doug Flutie Rob Johnson Alex Van
Pelt
um that Buffalo uh Wade Phillips Marv
Levy was our coach
um
yeah it was crazy man I walk into a
locker room wait were you uh were you on
the field for the Motor City Miracle no
Music City mirror Music City well you
were there I was there but I wasn't on
but you was on the back off team yeah
you weren't our special teams that was a
crazy
wow
talking about your life flashing before
your eyes crazy did that happen no we
were losing that whole game in part
because we didn't start Doug Flutie we
started Rob Johnson I remember that
whole debate and Rob Johnson had that
really interesting bandana he would wear
it really interested
so we we started the guy that the locker
room I would say mostly didn't support
yeah and didn't want so we're like all
right we're going out there a little
handicapped but let's go and they had
Javon curse that year I remember the
freak and they were playing Rick James
every time this sucker made a sack and
they played a lot of Rick James that
game right sucker was Tilton his rookie
year he was inside oh he was so good so
good so
they're they're beating us most of the
game and I remember the fans heckling us
we're in Tennessee they talking trash we
had the number one defense
um but it was a low scoring game but
they still were winning and everybody in
their head was like damn it Flutie was
playing one curse ain't gonna get to
Flutie like he's getting a ride because
he was mobile yeah yeah and two we were
like no we might be winning anyway
somehow some way we find a way where
we're leading and I think it's like 12
seconds to go nine seconds I don't know
it's something low all we got to do is
kick the ball off make the tackle game
over yeah yeah and I remember right
before the kickoff so the whole
Stadium's deflated and then the people
started to walk a little like just to go
yeah they're leaving yeah they're not
leaving but they're gonna they're gonna
stand at the top so yeah see the final
play and then try to get to the car for
everybody else yeah and we clowning them
we're like oh oh where y'all going
what's up and we like because we think
we're gonna win it all gonna do is kick
the ball off and then tackle the dude
they kicked that ball off and I think uh
Lorenzo Neal got it first now he's a
fullback so I'm not expecting him to
take off right but he's jogging and he's
a fullback so what's happening is slow
mo and I'm like what and I think he
threw it
uh him or white chick drew it to Dyson
now Dyson can roll he can roll throw it
across field yeah that's what it was low
Neal got to give him the white chick he
ran the sideways threw it and then and
when he did this everybody on the line
because you could see it we've seen too
much football we could see it developer
like
so my thought was I swear
it happened on the opposing sideline
Tennessee if it happened right in front
of me I would have took that penalty now
I don't know if they would have gave
them six right six points or they would
just say give them 20 yards right right
and I was like ain't no because you can
just see it there was no one in front of
him and we got sucked in he caught that
ball into the house and it was a wrap
after that you guys get to the locker
room after that ends what is said what
does Wade Phillips say what is like what
what is the like that's one of those
things where like how did it like what
happens in the locker room right after
that immediately yeah well the first
thing that happened was a 10 minute in
real time like instant replay like they
literally went under the hood for for
like 10 minutes kind of like the Tuck
Rule remember that yeah because this was
prior to there being challenges and all
that right yeah but they had to review
it right and they kept going kept going
the fans start crowding around the
officials like right up there in the
front row I mean it was a huge scrum and
he's just under there looking like I
mean forever just like the tough rule
was he was like like 20 minutes later
then he came out and he was like the
call stands or you know touchdown we
were like because we thought it was a
four lateral yeah kind of I mean but I
mean it was close MIT I think they did
it at MIT and they were like yeah it was
a four lateral by this degree but
whatever so then we get into the locker
room and not to exaggerate it it felt
like a traumatic experience like you
remember being in there but now you
reflect back I don't recall any of that
except crying everybody was like either
pissed or crying but I don't remember
one word from Wade I don't remember one
interaction with another guy I just
remember seeing tears people pissed off
and even me just sitting there crying
and there's an interview of me yelling
or talking trash about officiating and
Stuff Etc but this is a whole different
era man we just had to we had to eat it
we had to take it yeah because I just
finished a quarterbacks on Netflix have
you seen that
so Netflix has a show that they dropped
you should watch it okay it follows last
season Marcus Mariota Patrick Mahomes
and Kirk Cousins
seen the billboard somewhere it's so
good yeah they're really why let me let
me find out it's really good let me hear
why well one it lets you know how much
of like an absolute Maniac because it
follows Patrick Homes at home I'm here
with them all year he's a maniac for
real he's all in
um Kirk Cousins
you re you come out of it respecting him
so much more because he gets hell yeah
yes he played her all season last year
and I didn't know he was the most hit
quarterback in football last year I
didn't know that either so he was just
getting this Shaffer was hurt all last
year his ribs were [__] up the whole
year and they had one of the best
records in the league all year you know
and then they lost to the Giants in the
playoffs and then you see Marcus Mariota
and you realize the difference between
he might have all the talent in the
world but you see well you know but you
see everything right you see the
preparation you see the passion that
Kirk Cousins and Mahomes has and and to
me Mariota has kind of like a
he's just not into it like they are and
you're like what now how do you measure
that because I've played Julius Peppers
Hall of Famer oh yeah got caught up in
that where there's a physical
demonstration and like expression of
commitment and then there's some guys
who just like I'm showing you that but I
am committed yeah I just think Julius
Peppers is an alien too so yeah that's
different basketball player playing DN
yeah it's like a lot it's like
questioning Allen Iverson it's like yeah
but he's Allen Iverson yeah yeah Marcus
Mariota is not Allen Iverson but it I
came out of it being extremely scared
for the next 10 years about having to
you know I mean I'm a Cardinals fan so
it doesn't really matter we're not doing
[__] but just Mariota or uh Mahomes is
that guy oh come on but Kirk Cousins is
man he's a baller yeah see that's
another thing about like sports media
you got some you got a towel some I'm
over here on fire you got um I ain't
nervous to tell somebody I'm sweating
um
yeah the thing about
like I got a little mad too and here we
go thank you brother um I got mad at uh
just the coverage of a guy like her
cousins who's way better than what his
labor or narrative is right the
narrative is he's chokes and you know
never gonna win a Super Bowl with Kirk
cousin yeah yeah until he does or you
know if he does anything used to be that
way with Andy Reed by the way come on it
was Andy Reed look they they did that to
so many greats it was Rich Gannon who
never won when he got there but but was
a MVP and a machine got there so it's
like oh come on here's the thing why I
don't like it and it really hits me is
because I coach I got I coach my son
he's a seven-year-old and we out there
tilting like we win the Championships
every year we got Squad but the thing
that really hurts me is every single kid
that shows up their heroes are the
active players now some of them like
guys like a Dak Prescott like a Kirk
Cousins like it's not always just who is
the best right you know this they find
their guy and they love their guy
and I was like dog one day it hit me it
was crazy
I'm coaching my kids and their favorite
receivers a Cooper cup and all these
kind of guys you know they love my son
loves Austin Eckler whatever not the
best running back but one of the best
yeah
and then I go to work the next day and
I'm around and in the atmosphere where
they're tearing down my son's favorite
guy yeah and I was like and I'm
supporting this through either my
complicity or the fact that
you know you either silent or you're
actually contributing or sometimes you
fighting against it but that's just
engagement and people gonna chime in
even more so I am complicit in and I was
like dog I'm in some weird like Bizarro
Universe where I'm actually tearing down
some Heroes for my kid for my kid and
for a bunch of kids meanwhile I'm
telling this kid run uh stay in line
stay disciplined so he can be the best
he could be and pray he can make it to
the lead and now I'm over here watching
that happen to not only NFL guys but
like a Kevin Durant or Russell Westbrook
and like pick a man just tearing them
down from there especially Russ I mean
you wouldn't talk about somebody who's a
lot of kids Heroes that got tore down to
like I I mean listen thank God the
Clippers thing worked out but it was it
was like sad to see the way people were
talking about I'm like this is Russell
Westbrook I mean like this guy's a ma
he's probably my favorite player I've
ever watched in person just to see Russ
live up close with the Thunder
it was crazy yeah and he the homie too
he's a good dude
um look no one's perfect in terms of
listen yeah you can get into like what
you said you can get into the is it good
for winning on the Disney fit with the
Lakers you know but but keep your
respect kind of like Stripes like
letterman jackets like you are a doctor
I'm always call you Doctor yeah you're a
Hall of Fame you're a Hall of Fame I
always respect my name MVP yes y'all
coming at me like I'm just trying to
make it like I'm trying to do something
in this league and it's silly but that's
what I just kind of got fatigued of as
well in an overall sense of like
overarching this was like damn dog we
really tearing cash down just for some
ratings right just to pop because we got
an archaic rating system because we
competing against all these cats at home
on YouTube
we don't even tear cast down right he
doesn't no that's crazy you're right he
never does any of that [__] because he
know how hard it is and so he's a punter
saying man I'm propping up everybody and
if look the guy any self-deprecating
right you think I'm just a punter who do
I know right and I'm like dog there's an
alternative to this there's an alternate
universe that I need to go live in and
that's where I'm at now 100 man well I
think it's dope the YouTube channel is
doing great
um I'm getting that like in a week I
hope you get that that's dope 100 once
you once you hit the hundred thousand it
just gives you an option and they send
you one for free that's it yeah I need
that in my life yeah it's gonna happen I
wish they used to give one for 250 I
think because we just hit like 275. oh
you out here eating how long you've had
this uh we started it June 2020. no June
so uh about a year and three months into
the pandemic oh now was that pandemic
it's been about two years no the
pandemic's the best thing ever happened
to me that's what it made me it reshaped
my whole perspective on
what was important because I used to be
I started in the pandemic going to a
radio station every night for six hours
a day doing my show live the archaic way
yeah just changed everything for me damn
they said that pandemic like it either
broke you or made you better I heard
like I know how it was socially for me
but I was fat and full on on the day and
it was crazy I mean dude I mean I
remember just listening to the sports
podcast talking about the last dance
like it was happening live because there
was nothing else going on
it was like yep yep and the craziest
thing was I started because I moved
since then
um my boy Matt Linson I went to college
with my brother from another in 2018 he
was like dog you need to do a podcast
and I thought he was like almost
insulting me and it was weird because I
was like dog I'm listening to him him
and his wife there's like oh my God I
love podcast it's the best thing and
you're like man I ain't doing a pie I'm
on TV right not only that but I also
don't have the time but I was like I'm
gonna look into it no lie 2018 2019
uh uh I started in my pool house I was
like all right let me just you gave it a
shot I didn't even give it a shot set it
up got to the point where the mic's
going to turn on guess what I was like
damn it's hot as hell in there I sweat a
lot like you can tell right now and I
was like it's hot as hell here okay we
need to order an AC unit or have the AC
guy come out here before I start yeah
before I start
in that time
I saw a house that I was like yo this
dream house we got to move you gotta go
there you moved in that time and then I
moved and when I moved didn't reset up I
didn't reset yeah I was just like all
right all right maybe that was a sign
don't even do it and I literally moved
and I had this studio in the house and I
was like oh no I'm good I'm gonna just
keep doing this and then literally one
in September of last year I finally said
man I'm gonna be doing this no more
let's stop doing this and let's do it a
different way do it independent way and
then from September to like January I
was just like in the lab saying where's
your voice who are you for real what
what you love about before what you love
about this future how can you apply to
the new [__] yeah and I was just like
then I've got a little paralysis by
analysis I kept designing it and I was
like no no you're overthink it hell yeah
you're over overthink yourself in the
procrastination every time dog and I was
like that's what they were paying me for
over there don't think we got it I got
you just show up yeah and it's good and
there's a lot more to really do it
you're on your own because now you got
to do it's about the action and you're
afraid how people are going to receive
it for sure trust me I was there too
yeah it was weird like I I just was like
I was I was untraining myself from from
a lazier experience which was great
because it paid me and it gave me
platform but I was like change your life
my muscles man they out of shape right
like you know I mean like get to work
bro in a way that it is expressing
exactly who you are not just what the
machine is saying so then finally in
January I was just like let me do it
[__] it and then February I was like I
turned the cameras on January February I
said let's do this for real do it every
day and now we had like almost 100 000
subscribers already well congrats uh
last question yeah okay do you want the
Clippers to move on from this Kawaii
Paul George era yeah right I don't know
if that's gonna happen or not but but if
you tell me your thoughts on that era
and do we like to give it another year
also
how do you feel about James Harden
potentially wanting to come to the
Clippers and would you would you uh
would you welcome such things yeah look
it's so tough to give up on that dynamic
duo but they're not there when you need
them most the best availability or what
do they say the best abilities yeah and
we just can't trust that so it's a lot
of hope when you need actions the most
and look kawhi's knee is what it is he
took a year a year and a half off and
still couldn't even run off yeah yeah it
still couldn't make a playoff run right
so then you're like all right we got to
break it up just to reshuffle the deck
reimagine this situation and get a
different result it's Insanity to keep
doing the same thing expecting a
different result
problem is
Paul George is more available than Kauai
but Paul George is not Kawhi because
when Kawaii is on the top five right for
sure and Paul George's top 20 for sure
yeah beast but it's a different animal
ah
so they're gonna have to break it up but
I think they're gonna run it back one
more time as a Clipper fan do you ever
think I wish we never would have made
the trade because we would have had SGA
and all those picks no you know what
Shay gildress is I mean they talked them
with they talked us as fans they talked
to everyone through that process they
knew they were giving up a baller oh
baller but you got to take the swing if
you're the Clippers right you're the
Clippers right no first of all you're a
professional football basketball but
you're the Clippers like if you can get
two of the top 15 guys in the league top
five guy who just won a ring you gotta
try it yeah it's you gotta swing for the
fence that's why I'm not mad at my sons
we're swinging for the fences oh that
ishp is a wild boy man he's doing he
don't give a [__] about a second apron
first apron he's running through that's
it so we gotta swing for the fences I
think right now the strikeouts are
starting to add up where we gonna have
to change our swing that's all what
about Harding on the Clippers on paper I
don't see it especially because we got
Westbrook I don't see that I mean look
because that means Paul George is out
like someone's got to go somewhere
you're not gonna trade Kawhi are you
really no you have to change so Paul
George is gone we're going to use up
Westbrook to get us to the playoffs hope
for kawhi'll get us over the hump and
meanwhile yeah PG is a better fit than
James's so yeah so I don't I don't see
that style of ball Harden's a baller
still because when MB was hurt he did
his thing every single time he was like
let the league and assist yeah yeah
exactly also led the league in strip
club visits I can't talk to you no
that's only on an official record
unofficially somebody else got them beat
anyway I appreciate you man thank you
for pulling up big dogs boom go go make
sure you uh subscribe on YouTube you're
dropping it out daily right yeah daily
man we there every single day talking
Sports intersection of life and sports
and just breaking it down for real there
it is appreciate you brother all right
yes sir yes sir fire
hey this interview is brought to you by
our good Folks at hardean all right
shout out to the hardeen family in Las
Vegas make sure you follow them Harding
underscore Las Vegas the number one
dispensary period all right the craziest
selection of previous premium cannabis
you could ask for plus when you go to
Hardy in Las vegas.com you can check out
all the other cool stuff they got going
on you know they got a whole weed
University happening in Vegas hardine is
where it's at all right so if you're in
Las Vegas you get into that taxi cab you
say take me to Jardine and when you get
there you tell the wonderful Bud tenders
that I sent you and they're going to
take care of you Harding underscore Las
Vegas go follow him and uh yeah we got
another interview coming soon